news voice is the world's first mobile
app that helps you track
where your news is coming from news
voice helps you track what corporate
interests might be influencing the
narratives in the news you read every
day
arm yourself against corporate media
monopolies by downloading the news voice
app
for free using the link right underneath
this video
i'm going to go next to um
james from new york james from new york
you were on with me uh what's what's
going on in new york these days
james from new york you're on
hello that's you hey
you can hear me yes i can david hi
yeah my name is uh james i'm actually an
er doctor who just uh graduated uh out
of new york city
great um i've got a question for you
i'm wondering sort of all of these
different issues
abortion rights gay rights build the
wall
any sort of issue like this i almost
feel like we're sort of missing the
forest for the trees
in the idea that like unless we get
money out of politics register everybody
in the country to vote
it sort of seems like this system is
going to continue to stay
broken and that there's no way that we
can fix it unless we fix these sort of
like
the electoral college money in politics
absolutely correct yeah so i've said for
a while that whatever you care about
whether it's abortion education
um whatever your issue is gay
rights tax rates you know whatever the
case may be there's a package of meta
issues that need to be dealt with it's a
more systemic
issue that includes money in politics
and
combined with money in politics it's the
way media operates which is very much
influenced by money in politics we have
to deal with how elections are done so
we're talking about you know electoral
college is a problem
55 voter turnout in presidential
elections is a problem that's a really
big
first pass the post is a problem got to
deal with that and then number three
climate climate actually is a meta issue
a lot of people don't consider
but if your city is underwater or you're
in the hospital
because of the pollution in your city
it's hard to be an activist
when that is is the the situation in
terms of climate and honestly
even though health care is a political
issue if you don't have health care and
you're sick
it's also going to be hard to be an
activist so those are kind of like the
four meta issues that
if we really want to fix things you have
to deal with you're spot on
yeah it sort of seems like it's a
beautiful system that has
been created to sort of basically
distract
the everyday voter from these
generalized problems
and just get them focused on oh well
everyone else is lazy
or you know you need to just man up and
get over your issues
and that nobody it's almost like the
rats fighting over the scraps while the
one percent just convince
basically convinces conservatives to
vote for rich people keeping their money
yeah a lot of times what what i
recommend to people is when you're
you're embroiled in a you're thinking
about a political issue or you're
embroiled in a political debate ask
yourself whether you're even
debating the right question so for
example the debate over to what degree
can people pull themselves up by their
bootstraps
it's a ridiculous debate we we know the
answers we have data on class mobility
we have data on the impact of not having
you know having hunger
or of not having health care and the
effect that this has on class mobility
it's
it's the wrong debate and it might be
fun for you know people who go and speak
at colleges and
argue with college kids or whatever the
case may be but um we know
that these meta issues are an impediment
to solving
any of these problems when it comes
right down to it
so i guess my question is how do we
solve
this like really like how do we even fix
this country
i mean as a starting point if we don't
actually get
competent leadership controlling the
white house the house and the senate and
most of the governor's mansions
for at least four years and make some
progress
it's going to be very difficult and
that's again the system is meant to
perpetuate itself it's almost
it's almost like natural selection in a
sense the system survives because it's
most likely to perpetuate itself
and it perpetuates itself because it
survives it's a circle
yeah yeah i couldn't agree more i have
all these conversations with different
people
of different sort of socioeconomic and
racial backgrounds
and it just seems like emotion takes
over
and no real rational discussions take
place it's like your political party
is your team right and not actually
is this benefiting you and i just i like
honest to god i'm really
un in fear on november and they have
this election and
trump's going to declare victory and
what is you know
50 million people or whatever who voted
for them what do you do when your
president says
i've won and if they try and take it
from me you need to take to the streets
that's that that's my fear exactly
listen before i let you go as an er
doctor
what is going on in ers at this point
what are you seeing
um so it's it sort of depends
on where you are but at least in the
around the new york city area
cases are starting to spike again yeah
um it seems like
i don't want to you know you know
single out a single group but it seems
like it's religious gatherings
and it's nursing homes and they're just
sort of relaxing standards
and the numbers are especially around
the city
they're starting to rise and we are
either everybody who got super sick
already got
sick and we're gonna be okay or we're
gonna do the same thing we did back in
march and april
and i don't know how health care
workers and the general populace i don't
know how we get through it if we do the
same thing that happened back in march
so when you tell someone hey you have
coronavirus
are are people surprised in the sense
that they're not connecting their
actions to getting the virus
um well yeah sort of
um it's also difficult just explaining
to people in general
that because the prevalence of this
virus is so low that a negative test
doesn't mean anything um you could have
five negative tests and you could still
have the virus
that's just based on like statistics
with the prevalence being so low
um it's just hard because it's also
matters how you do the test
and a lot of healthcare people don't
want to shove that swab super
deep up the nose so it's a negative test
but maybe it's really not
negative um yeah it's and
you know we still have a lot of the
tests in a lot of these hospitals are
taking six hours to come back
right he got sitting in the er for six
hours it's
i mean it's almost as if everything we
went through in march
changed nothing about how we're handling
it right from
leadership in the hospitals to the
statewide to the national level
it's really scary to be honest with you
hey last thing
and then i gotta run are your in the er
you're not actually doing any
coronavirus treatment right like
the any if people are getting anything
from rim desevere to dexamethasone or
anything like that that's once they've
been admitted
well so usually what happens is if we
suspect and they
look bad we'll start a couple of these
treatments
um but if they're looking okay you just
swab them make sure there's no other
pneumonia or other sort of infection and
then you just send them home with
quarantine precautions oh i see
um yeah but it's sort of hard to say i
know the steroids help but it's usually
only it's sicker people
but the ones that sort of look sick or
throwing the mack truck at him because
we really don't know what this virus
does yeah what's that
all right james from new york i
appreciate you uh talking to us today
it's a pleasure thanks for having me on
i love your show there's james from new
york er doctor we're going to take a
quick break
if you are holding don't hang up because
we will go right back to the phones
momentarily